o corpo sob pressão mas o vídeo e hoje a
fazer num tacho para aqui o ppa
inventada por me fazer estas para usar
só de acolher operando em mais dois
produtos pequeninos que tancredo fez
muito barulho que vocês vão ver no
tutorial é isso aê sol mas na hora de
exibir mostrada em uma briga pequenina
mas enfim eu já só lá porque o sono isto
vai fazer nada que vocês acabaram de ver
se vocês não tiverem petróleo podem usar
outras folhas quaisquer caderno quatro
ou cinco estrelas cola ou fita crepe
o grande colar sim fazer o mesmo com o
outro lado
já agora é mais uma amiga o que quer
fazer uma grande até o final
temos que aprender mais rápido por aqui
fita crepe é feito para aumentar a
resistência é antecipada porque é uma
coisa simples leva num canto
a não ser que um tubinho esta parte aqui
eu vou aprender com fita crepe grande
nos pontos já está agora num fica mais
firme dentro da sacola
já está mais ou menos a lâmina feita
agora ficar mais bonita e mais esta
parte aqui fica melhor e pronto a lâmina
já está feito agora fazer parte do
público que tem muitas coloridas
[Música]
agora as linhas então vou ter aqui para
fazer existe
enquanto ainda com fita cola está parte
opcional vocês podem fazer o do mundo
pode usar a voz e criatividade estação
exemplo está agora precisará fazer mais
ou menos a maio mas a linha para fazer o
mesmo por esse lado é baixar o centro
agora esta parte aqui mesmo no centro
já marquei largura e agora vou fazer que
o centro desta linha para que se entenda
aqui também mas centro fazer que o
design da lâmina
agora vou cortar isso com a ajuda do x
dados
[Música]
e pronto agora é só enrolar até o final
da folha e pronto agora vou aprender
aqui e agora vamos fazer o mesmo que
fizeram aqui
e pronto está melhor é só por isto
aqui podem só apostar num cadinho só
pagar mais de 15
agora fazer só uma coisa para ficar mais
na edição em gola minha fazer um corte
no ensino integral devem deixar nos
comentários sugestões de projetos pode
fazer também uma espada é genial seu
próximo vídeo tem que dar adeus que o
japão fica o sítio 5 4 3 2
vamos lá